I would say there are two
critical aspects to film noir.
One is the visual language,
and one is the story language.
The visual language, like horror,
it comes extremely influenced
by German Expressionism.
a cinema of chiaroscuro
of light and shadow.
I grew up with film noir.
You know, they were
people's movies.
They weren't fancy Hollywood.
They were tough,
pessimistic, scary fantasies.
It's ultimately a moral
decision, your honor.
You have characters
that have not and tried
to get it through violence.
They tried to break that barrier
that society denies them.
That makes it
a really interesting
existential American tragedy.
And of course, I loved that
they were vital
and they were kind of B-movies.
The commonality between
noir and tragedy
is the inexorable,
you know it's going to end bad.
That's very attractive
to see these
desperate stories.
You could empathize
with these people,
but there was always
a little bit of it,
“I understand, but that's not me.”
When people talk about noir,
people think immediately
of a cliché, a perfume ad.
Venetian blinds, voice over,
detective in that overcoat
in a wet street,
slow-moving fan, smoking
dame in the half shadow.
That's not noir. The figure
of the femme fatale,
they were women with agency.
And they got it any way
they could
because the game was rigged.
This fate of the world and
themselves in the world,
that's very attractive
when you're a young kid
and you're trying to
figure out who you are.
I actually like a lot
of lesser-known noirs.
Born to Kill, Too Late for Tears
The brutal, inexorable
quality of noir
is that the wheels keep
grinding these characters.
It’s a beautifully brutal genre.